9-річний Арсеній радіє, що поїдев літній табір.
А от у його мами Алли на серці неспокійно.
Жінка вже не вперше відправляє дітей на відпочинок.
Поки що негативного досвіду не мала.
Але тепер її лякають повідомлення про отруєння
понад сотні дітей улітніх таборах цього літа.
Я, мабуть, так само, як інші батьки, наче розумію, що
все має бути в порядку.
Але, знову ж таки, треба все перевіряти…
Ціна, місце і програма відпочинку - це лише частина факторів
при виборі літнього табору.
DWвирішила з'ясувати, на що слід зважати батькам,
перш ніж довірити своє чадо вихователям на канікули.
Дитячийтабір треба перевірити в реєстрі.
Він надає інформацію, яка у того чи іншого таборукатегорія
і чи пройшов він державну атестацію.
На Київщині, приміром, далеко не всі табори це зробили.
У документі має бути чітко прописана відповідальність
керівництва табору та персоналу
у разі виникнення різних надзвичайних ситуацій.
- Добрий день!
Як можна дізнатися , чи має табір дозвільні документи на роботу?
Якщо статуту на вимогу вам не надають, це вже тривожний сигнал.
Батькам слід ознайомитися з висновком Держспоживслужби
про відповідність медико-санітарним нормам кухні
та інших приміщень літнього табору. За даними служби,
35% закладів минулого сезону ці вимоги порушували.
Щоб не потрапити в неприємну історію,
батьки можуть перевірити документи, які підтверджують якість води
та продуктів від постачальників. Це має бути підкріплено
офіційними договорами з конкретними фірмами.
- Можливо, Ви підкажете за лікаря.Хто відповідає?
Де це можна дізнатися?
У лікарні?
Слід з'ясувати, чи є у таборі офіційно працевлаштований лікар
та інший медперсонал, до якої лікарні повезуть дитину в разі нещасного випадку.
А також чи є в наявності необхідні ліки для надання первинної медичної допомоги.
Держслужба з надзвичайних ситуацій перевіряє табори,
чи дотримані норми техніки безпеки.
Тому слід поцікавитися відповідним висновком.
Минулоріч, приміром, з виявлених ДСНС6000 порушень
у літніх таборах 40% так і не було усунуто.
Батьки в соцмережах та на різних форумах
активно діляться своїм досвідом щодо літніх таборів.
Там можна почерпнути багато корисної інформації
та обмінятися питаннями, які вас турбують.
Варто поінформувати дитину про її права і домовитися,
як дитина має вийти на зв'язокз батьками
у разі якихось проблем. Арсеній вважає себе підкутим щодо цього.
- Я знаю, що всі діти мають права.
Якщо їх хтось порушує, то я піду до директора
або до вихователя і розповім це…
Мама Арсенія каже, що витратила більше трьох годин
на збір інформації про літній табір, куди вирушає її син.
Але вважає це добре інвестованим часом.
Бо тепер з легшим серцем відправляє Арсенія на відпочинок.